hello everyone Karen Gordon with film
crews radio show we're outside the
studio with John Reese writer of think
outside the box office and Jeffrey
winter co-director of the film Calabria
that's correct okay and we also had
sherek hammer social media strategist
for indie film on the show today talking
about selling your film without selling
your soul and some of the comments that
were going on on Twitter during the show
or that you know what you were book or
what we were talking about today really
gears more toward the US and not abroad
where so many people are not sure what
is streaming netflix and these different
p oh do you think so can you touch on
that well the two things I would say is
I think a lot of the basic principles
are similar for selling in the US and
selling foreign it just depends on what
your market is but I think the basic
principles of audience identification
and engagement partnerships live events
merchandise and digital you can apply
those to any country wherever you happen
to be based and you could also apply
them if you're based in the United
States you can also apply those to
foreign territories as well I think it's
hard when you're a us filmmaker to
especially when you're doing a director
without a distributor to go for it i
mean it's it's hard enough to do your
own market much less go to a foreign
market but more and more there are tools
now that enable you to do that and
especially like in cherries chapter
where she's talking about direct p2p and
a lot of its internet distribution
that's global you know it's not just us
centric it's it's all if I myself
looking at you while i'm talking about i
can tell you over here but a lot of it
is you can take all of these principles
apply them globally and the other thing
is is that there are one of our sponsors
dynamo and then one of our other code or
district why are they and egg up each of
those sponsors actually do global
digital distribution DIY direct
distribution so you can engage any of
those platforms to reach an audience
globally so it's very once you start
engaging an audience worldwide through
social media you can also now access
them worldwide through these various
platforms and then also topspin which is
I need to say another sponsor but we
should talk about our sponsors a little
bit that's also a shopping cart and
people can buy the things from all over
the world that you can you know it's all
these because you know even though we're
talking about the US and we're all
american in a number of our case studies
or most of our case or days or US base
it doesn't mean that all of these
techniques and methodologies can't be
applied worldwide and obviously netflix
is expanding worldwide you know they
keep adding countries but i do want to
say that there is a reason at this stage
that we're talking mostly about the u.s.
because there are many parts of the
world that they that the streaming
technology is just not as advanced yet
and we get a lot of pushback basically
for example i've tried as distributors
we've tried so hard to get to get rid of
dvds stop sending screeners out you know
I mean that would be my biggest cost as
a distributor is just postage and if I
could just a say no more dvds I'm just
sending out links all over the world I
mean that would radically change the
distribution business world but
unfortunately most people still come
back to me and say I can't watch it my
screen is not big enough it buffers you
know we we just and so I get a lot of
pushback trying to enter the digital age
on a global scale so we still really do
need to work with partners other small
distributors other district platforms in
other countries I don't think we're at
that place technologically where the
conversation is easy to have as a global
phenomenon the one advantage though is
in this little transitional moment
is that you can still sell dvds for you
know and so there's a lot of countries
organized in australia give their
blockbusters everywhere it's like oh my
god and because there's the broadband
because the lot of countries just don't
have really robust broadband
infrastructure yet but that's all going
to change we're in the next five to ten
years in 10 years it will all be a more
like the US model you know VOD is also
something that's difficult there isn't
it isn't as established as it is in the
United States and it isn't as open as it
is in the United States and so in a
sense you know you know a lot of these
techniques a lot of these that we're
talking about have been done in the
United States first or you know more
prominently because it's just impossible
it's easier to do it here and it's also
you know to be perfectly honest we are
all Americans and we deal with American
filmmakers on a more direct basis you
know and I would say that's also part of
it but we hear from filmmaker and I you
know it's just in England as wondering
like you know I was doing one of my
workshops it's like well you know I
always try to be sensitive is to make
sure that it's relevant for the look for
people for the filmmakers in those
countries and I find that the things
that I talked about here are just as
relevant for the people in foreign
countries and I would say that the phone
glad we work with a lot of foreign
filmmakers but yet predominantly on
access to the US market and as he says
he said DVDs we still rely predominantly
on foreign partners to help us get it
out into the market there and are not at
the place yet I mean we're all changing
and striving to be that way but direct
distribution digitally in other
countries is not something we've been
achieved robustly yet right and the one
thing I'll say about Ed up which I like
about their model is that you know
because because streaming is difficult
in many countries the reason they set up
this in case download to own formula was
because of the recognition that
streaming is it is robust in foreign
country so there are alternatives you
know to you know that are slowly
developing you know too
hands that that kind of direct
distribution in foreign territories but
I hope my own as offended we love
Oh